dans le nord-isère un accident s'est
produit entre un véhicule et un camion
citerne provoquant une fuite le camion
transportait 19 mille litres de 18
furent de carbone un produit instable et
inflammable le merdier les gars pour
ceux qui vont sur lyon difficile de ne
pas perdre patience donc voilà donc là
les gens font demi tour sur l'autoroute
il ya des gens qui ont démonté la
rambarde voilà pour passer ici et ici
des dizaines de soldats l'ukrainien en
file indienne kit lusine daz opstal les
visages sont marqués il l'est imaginé
pour certains la violence des combats
qui se sont déroulés ici à nantes des
professeurs exercent leur droit de
retrait après une agression la semaine
dernière au lycée de la herdrie près de
nantes en plein couvre une enseignante a
été visée par un pistolet à eau nous ne
sommes pas sur le perron de l'elysée je
ne suis pas le secrétaire général de
l'elysée donc je ne vais pas vous
annoncer l'album de la composition et de
leur ordination à caractère très
symbolique vous avez vous l'avez alors
si on peut revenir aux déplacements levé
aujourd'hui elle est venue elle était
ministre de l'écologie je pense que je
ne vais pas appeler comme cela
c'était plus pompeux que ça et elle
était venue c'était pour des c'était des
inondations voilà et elle l avait au nom
du gouvernement a annoncé qu'on aurait
de l'argent de cette élimination
terrible et tout ça il n'y a pas eu un
roncquois qu'est ce qui met du temps
remaniement attendait monsieur moi j'ai
été nommé il ya quelques jours et je
vous dis on va pas se mettre la pression
de décider là tout de suite maintenant
on veut la meilleure équipe mais bien
sûr le travail continue manière sérieuse
mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas une chose
légère que autant de temps utile et que
nécessaire car il s'agit du gouvernement
de la france on nous impose des trois
fois la question je vous laisse cas des
ministres sk des futurs ministres
derrière vous bah vous verrez alerte
enlèvement où est passée la droite dit
d'où on en est des petites nouvelles à
travers les chicaillas entre damien abad
christian jacob l'un demande à l'autre
de quitter de que d'éclaircir la
situation certains élus attendent aussi
le verdict macro n'y a un peu tendu
comme damien abad dlr a tenté de
rejoindre la majorité qui n'a toujours
pas décidé car il ne sait pas encore
s'il sera nommé au gouvernement
et ça commence à tendre son patron
christian jacob il a demandé un délai de
48 heures le délai de 48 heures est là
maintenant soit il rejoint la majorité
il le dit il assume il veut rentrer au
gouvernement parce qu'on le veut
conduire mais après s'il souhaite
rentrer gouvernement il y va mais que
les choses soient claires
ah
c'est vrai que c'était surprenant qu'ils
demandent 48 heures raison disait bon
genre de choses on le sait si on a envie
d'y aller ou pas bon maintenant sans
doute kiki qui s'interrogent mais il
doit effectivement dire clairement les
choses aux sorcières forte laquelle de
nos 650 mesure est plus précise et rend
possible le débat ce qui est bien je ne
m'en plains pas qu'on discute des
contenus plus précises que par exemple
une mesure comme celle de l'alliance
renaissance mieux reconnaître les
enseignants danube est ce qu est une
sorte de 2,2 à généralité on est parent
jean luc mélenchon qui a décidé de
sortir la carte magouilles comme si on y
lisait les premiers ministres dans le
pays et jean luc mélenchon à zéro chance
d'être premier ministre bien une
politique ambitieuse pour la santé des
femmes ou bien transformer l'état par le
numérique ce que nous l'avons
certainement pas l'intention de faire
puisque nous comptons transformer l'état
par son humanisation pourquoi des états
unis justement un produit important
là-bas y connaît une pénurie lequel
c'est le lait pour bébé à cause de
problèmes d'approvisionnement d'un
manque de main-d'oeuvre liées à la crise
sanitaire les rayons de lait en poudre
vous voyez pour nourrissons sont
totalement vide